I voted today it was president rugs
White House communications director
here's what you need to know he calls
himself the mooch that's it that's all
you need to know
Anthony scare emoji everybody mooch can
I can I call you the mooch you can call
me the mooch moach anything you want I'm
gonna call you the mooch I want to talk
leeks last week White House aide Kelley
Sadler said of John McCain it doesn't
matter he's dying anyway that's rough I
mean that's obviously an inappropriate
thing to say it's you know I think she
apologized in private and there was
thoughts about her apologizing in public
I have no idea why she's not apologizing
in public but it would be a good idea
for her to do that yeah so what your
wife why doesn't she come out and
apologize a long-standing feud with the
senator and I think you know there's
been a political feud there but like as
I've said that he is a American patriot
you don't have to agree with him
politically but the truth of the matter
is we have to move past it and I think
you are catching wind that the White
House is got a bunch of leakers in there
that was a hit job on Kelly
Sadler now raise your hand in this room
if you've never said anything that you
regret I know I have I mean one of the
things that I say they got a lot of it's
on tape one of one of the things not a
lot of it thank God some of it thank God
a lot of it isn't on tape just a little
bit of its architecture but but the but
the truth of the matter is you know
people do you know people say things
they say things they regret and so
hopefully they won't fire Kelly she's
great at her job she's been very loyal
to the president and she's not a leaker
by the way so she's a classy person well
what is the issue with these leaks that
are coming out right now it's a bad
culture you know you've got a group of
people and they really only care about
themselves they don't really care about
the President's agenda um they obviously
are all anonymous they do it
surreptitiously it's a currency with the
journalists and so they call up the
journalists and they leak nefarious
things about each other I mean the fact
that they're having a conversation about
leaking and Sarah Huckabee who I think
is awesome professional says okay I'm
gonna say something now and it's
probably gonna get leaked to the press
and then the exact words that she's
saying gets leaked
the press is a sign of the rampant
dishonesty that's in the system or that
she can see into the future yeah yeah
well I hope she sees good things for you
and me baby
fingers crossed yeah well I'm pretty
good about it though you like it feels
good yeah no I like our report
thank you very much yeah feels
guilty yeah Geordie good the left is
gonna push back and they're gonna say
these leaks that are coming out of the
White House they're emblematic of a
larger problem that they come from on
high that people are upset with the
president is it did you point blame it
what the environment Donald Trump John
Kelly a lot of these guys got got into
the White House they were astonished at
the president won some of them were
frankly book or a lot of these guys you
know it's it's it's not know like this
don't work come on guys I got I got I
got to be honest with you I would be
very happy to name them but I'd have to
look at the roster I don't really
remember from six eight nine months ago
just a triage that's the truth see this
is the project I don't like to name them
but I'm happy to name him but I just
don't remember I if you show me the
roster I could pick out the leakers and
you can put the to diet you don't have
to be Carrie Mathison from homeland to
figure out who's doing the leak it's
very easy to figure it out okay let's
say so so but here's the problem okay
the the culture got set up that way by
Reince Priebus he flooded the place with
never Trump errs he flooded the place
with Oran see people that don't like the
president and so now they're going after
the president 18 months into the
presidency and so it's nonsensical and
those people either need to stop and
there needs to be a forcible change in
culture or they need to be removed it's
really that simple so what do you do if
you the mooch is back the White House if
I had 12 days I would have fired three
or four more people as I say yeah and
then if I had 15 days I would have
probably fired another three or four
more people and then I guarantee you
that the leaking would have stopped much
I want to talk about Sean Hannity big
news article came out today that he's
almost talking daily with President
Trump do you like that do you like to
see finally but Trump finding his people
in the media so he can get his message
out like the big hamster I thought he
was taught I
I thought he was talking to you daily
I'm like very disciplined checking in
with him every now and then you are yeah
yeah does he like that hairstyle i mean
i don't know i mean that's the medicine
test with hair you know that yeah i mean
the way you're doing that though is like
fantastic it's like right up there with
the donald you really i like that's how
if you put a little bit of an orange
highlight in there i think I can get you
the comp job and really yeah that's a
little bit of an orange highlight you'll
be fantastic look I love Shawn he's one
of my best friends he's close to the
president i I don't think it's any
problem for him to be talking to the
president I think you know and I know
anything after eight o'clock on these
networks or opinion pieces and so
Shawn's
loaded with opinions I don't think
they're looking at him the same way
they're looking at other people in the
news organization having said all that I
think he's a very very good
investigative journalist I think he's
uncovered a lot of things but is it but
do you think that's is it the left is
gonna push back they're gonna say like
he should be talking to experts and not
journalists with opinions or opinion
makers who say they're journalists I
mean listen more guys Sean Hannity you
guys you guys don't you guys don't like
it I like Sean I think Sean's a very
accomplished guy he's a he's been a
brilliant entrepreneur and he's close to
the president his family I don't see a
big deal we'll talk about the old gangs
you ever get to see the old gang that
Stevie two shorts the self later or
rancid penis you ever get to see him he
two shorts why would you call him that
because of the self fellating well he's
self Falaise but he's guy he wears the
two shirts I like the sloppy Steve thing
I think that's fun I ate off I like
quantum ate off ban and once in a while
I think that's fun oh yeah
well that's what he's like yeah well
that's what he's like I mean just pay
close attention did you talk to Donald
Trump once in a while yeah does it ever
say today about me yeah he loves your
show yeah yeah if you get like I said if
you get me your resume I think you and
John Kelly would get along unbelievably
yeah yeah probably as well as John Kelly
and I got along mooch tell me something
I already know you're gonna see peace
and the North Korean Peninsula you see
foldy nuclearization of the peninsula
and you're probably going to see a deal
with the Iranians at some point a good
deal for the United States that already
knew after a scare emoji the fight
continues
[Applause]
[Music]